ولماذا التركيز فقط حتى الان مع همم
السائقيين ماذا عن باقي فئات الشعب الى اي
مداه يتضرر الشعب الاردني اليوم بهذه
الزياده في المحروقات
الجهود الامنيه لمكافحه اعمال الشغب
ومكافحه اعمال الارهاب اللي ادت الى وفاه
حتى هذه اللحظه الى اربع رجال امل رحمه
الله ولكن حقيقه منذ بدايه هذا الشهر منذ
اقامه الحكومه برفع اسعار المشتقات
النفسيه بدات مع سائق الشاحنات وانتقلت
الى السائقين السيارات للركوب والان
انتشرت في مختلف عن حال المملكه اللي
يشارك فيها
طبقات اجتماعيه مختلفه وكما هو معروف هذه
الاسباب ليست جديده هي اسباب قديمه ويكون
عند السنوات احنا في الاردن بنشهد مجموعه
من الاحتياجات نساء تطبيق سياسات اقتصاديه
ذات طابع تقشف في حقيقه لا تاخذ بعين
الاعتبار ومستويات المعيشيه للمواطنين همم
منذ عقود والاردن ويطبخ سياسات ضريبيه
حقيقه غير عادله هناك توسع كبير في
الضرائب مباشره
بكل انواعها الضريبه العامه على المبيعات
او رسوم الجمركيه او الضرائب المقطوعه
الحكومه لم تكتفي حقيقه بطلبات صندوق
النقد الدولي بوقف الدعم على المشتقات
النفطيه كما حدث قبل الاكثر من قبل ما
يقارب العقدين وانما الان هي تقوم بفرض
رائد كبيره على مشتقات النفسيه ومختلف
انواعها والمشتقات النفسيه في الاردن
اسعارها من بين اعلى النسب في العالم لذلك
انا بعتقد انه الحكومه الان مطلوب منها
انها تتراجع بشكل ملموس عن فرض الضريبه
التي تتراوح بين حوالي 18% الى ما يقارب
من 50 فيها مشتقات النفطيه حسب انواعها
وهذا ادى الى ارتفاع كبير بمستويات
الاسعار راشق ذلك انه مستويات الاجور يتم
الضغط عليها منذ عده سنوات باتجاه عدم
الارتفاع لاسباب لا نعرف حقيقه الا انها
تخدم طبقات اجتماعيه دون اخرى وهذا ادى
الى ضيق غالبيه المواطنين في الاردن سواء
كانوا عاملين او غير عامرين ذلك معادلات
الفقر بشكل ان الموسم البنك الدولي بتح عن
معدلات صقر 35% الحكومه اردني يتحدث عن
24% معدلات البطانه بين الشباب تقارب 47
48% وبين مجمل المجتمع حوالي 22.4% هذه
الاوضاع غير قابله للاستمرار واحنا بنتوقع
انه يتم الاستجابه لهذه المطالب الخلاف
ذلك ستبقى الاحتياجات قائمه شكرا جزيلا لك
سيد احمد عوض
من عمان